Apple did it again and accidentally
leaked brand new unreleased airpods
which are likely coming later this year
the hard part is figuring out exactly
which pair of airpods is getting
refreshed or what if it's an entirely
new
never-before-seen airpods product well
let's do some digging to find out now as
for the leak that we just got there are
actually two new earpods products that
was leaked within iOS 16.4 yes that
means that somebody from Apple left some
references to a couple of new airpods
products as you can see right here from
Aaron on Twitter iOS 16.4 reference new
airpods with the model number
a30048 and a new airpods case with the
model number
a2968 now before we get into figuring
out what the new airpods product is
let's first talk about the airpods case
as you probably already heard online
we've got some leaked case cads of the
entire iPhone 15 lineup like right here
you can see the new iPhone 15 Pro with a
redesigned thinner bezels and no
lightning Port yes the same thing for
the pro Max version right here you can
see USB type c and same thing for the
regular iPhone 15 even that model USBC
and also the iPhone 15 plus they are all
switching over to the brand new USBC
port and we've also been having leaks
from Ming Shaco who is very reliable
saying that USBC is going to be on the
iPhone 15 lineup enabling faster
charging speeds but only with certified
cables which means apple is going to be
making their money and last year Ming
shiko did say that the new airpods Pro 2
would likely have a lightning charging
case which they do this is the airpods
Pro 2 right here with a USBC model
coming in 2023 which is this year so I
think that the leaked model number for
the airpod God's case is actually just
airpods Pro 2 identical to how they are
now with a brand new USBC case now if
you didn't already know when Apple
released the airpods 3 those ones came
with Mac safe charging support So at the
same time Apple released the regular
airpods Pro with a different charging
case that you could even buy separately
or all together with Max save support So
in that case why wouldn't they simply
make a new USBC charging case for the
airpods Pro 2 when the iPhone 15 lineup
launches this September it totally makes
sense to me and now let's get into what
that brand new mystery airpods product
could be I honestly don't think that
it's going to be the airpods 4 because
the threes just came out and they're on
a 2.5 year timeline if you take a look
at the history of the earpods there was
exactly two and a half years between the
original airpods and airpods 2 and
exactly the same time from airpods 2 to
3 so with that knowledge we shouldn't
expect the airpods for until the spring
of 2024. now what about the airpods Pro
3 well it is way too early because they
just came out in September so it's
impossible to get the third generation
of these guys at least for the next
couple of years and then that of course
leaves the airpods max yes the overhead
ones that many people seem to forget
about they are still considered airpods
especially in Apple's IOS software now
those came out about two years ago so
what if apple is simply gonna release
the airpods max 2 later this year with a
USBC port and that would be the missing
model that was leaked well in that case
it would actually make a whole lot of
sense but definitely not before the
iPhone 15 comes out with the USBC Port
so it would have to happen after that
and maybe even in December again like it
did for the original release that could
totally make sense but it's not just
going to be a new model with a USBC Port
it's going to be a completely new second
generation model with probably better
speakers drivers better noise
cancellation and a bunch of other
upgraded features and the thing about
the airpods max is that I actually
bought a pair yes I own one of these I
finally caved bought one used them they
were great but then the airpods Pro 2
came out and surprisingly those in-ear
earbuds sound just as good as the
airpods max maybe even a little better
which blew my mind so the airpods max
definitely need an update with better
sound quality so maybe that's why Apple
will be upgrading them later this year
however ever even though it can make a
whole lot of sense for the airpods max
to be that leaked model I think it could
be something completely different a
brand new never-before-seen airpods
product and that leads me to this
exclusive leak from nine to five Max
showing off the new Beats Studio buds
plus headphones coming as well as those
unreleased airpods that were referenced
now the rider of that nine to five Mac
article Felipe Esposito gave a really
good take on Twitter of what it could be
he says we don't know for sure but it
could be the rumored airpods light yes
the air pods light now if you haven't
heard about that let's get into it
earlier this year we actually got a
fresh report from Jeff who from haitong
International Tech research saying that
apple is working on airpods light
whatever that means to compete with the
keeper wireless earbuds out there
because right now the airpods 2 aren't
really doing that well with competing
they suck compared to the competition
now a couple days ago we made a video
comparing the brand new nothing ear 2
headphones for a hundred and fifty
dollars to the airpods Pro 2 and
surprisingly they actually did a killer
job compared to the airpods Pro 2. in
fact in one song they sounded better so
a hundred dollars cheaper than the
airpods Pro 2 and they sounded better
and very close across the board so that
is challenging apple and if Apple wants
to compete with those lower end
headphones they're gonna need the
airpods light and the crazy thing is
that this isn't the first time somebody
has mentioned airpods light we've had
leaks before with the light branding of
course Apple's probably not going to
call it that but there were some leaks
about a budget airpods model coming out
now what could it be be well some people
are saying it could just be the airpods
2 at an even lower price let's say only
99 dollars for a pair of earpods but
what if it's something completely new
with some tuned down specs maybe some
kind of unique design for that lower
price replacing the airpods too that
could definitely be a really good seller
but with that said we don't really know
what it's going to be so we can only
wait let me know down in the comments
section below what you think the new
unreleased pair of airpods is going to
be thanks for watching click that Circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one definitely check out one of
those two right there and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
thank you